le système d'urgence a été activé dans
la centrale nucléaire de zappos ridja en
ukraine le site a été la cible d'un
nouveau bombardement au mortier l'un des
réacteurs est à l'arrêt voilà pour le
comité d'accueil des agents de l'aiea
vous les voyez ils sont une douzaine ses
techniciens de l'agencé internationale
de l'énergie atomique qui vient donc
d'arriver sur le site nucléaire pour
pouvoir l'inspecter alors que je le
disais les bombardements sont quasi
quotidiens et qui est que les deux camps
se rejettent la responsabilité
james andré et bonjour vous êtes notre
envoyé spécial dans la ville de happo
ridja c'est donc une partie pour une
mission périlleuse
oui absolument donc ça y est on le sait
la mission de l'aiea est arrivé sur
place ça a été compliqué normalement il
faut environ deux heures pour rallier la
centrale nucléaire de zaporijia qui
seront trouve en réalité dans la ville
denner radars depuis la ville de zappos
ridja et bien ils ont mis beaucoup plus
de temps tout simplement parce que ils
ont été arrêtés par les autorités
militaires ukrainienne en terrain
ukrainien ça c'est des informations que
nous détenons du de l'attachée de presse
qui est dans le convoi et qui nous a
communiqué ce la paroisse de sap il a
expliqué bien qu'il avait fallu que
raphaël grossi lui même descendre de
voiture et a négocié avec les autorités
militaires et ukrainienne pour pouvoir
continuer son chemin vers la centrale
nucléaire dans la centrale nucléaire
elle même eh bien ils sont maintenant
sur place cette inspection va pouvoir
commencer alors que effectivement il ya
eu de l'activité militaire tout autour
de cette centrale la nuit dernière et
durant la matinée c'est ce qu'on a
entendu ici avec notamment et nargue
erratum qui est l'opérateur pour
l'énergie nucléaire
en ukraine qui a annoncé un peu plus tôt
dans la journée que le réacteur numéro 5
s'était arrêté suite à une frappe
d'artillerie à proximité de la centrale
les russes pour leur part font état et
bien d'un débarquement d'un commando
depuis le nièvre qu'ils auraient
intercepté et je cite neutraliser donc
les deux parties qui continuaient à se
renvoyer la responsabilité de ses
frappes et ces explosions qui ont lieu
autour de cette centrale nucléaire à
l'heure où effectivement la ja arrive
espérant installé une mission pérenne de
surveillance du site james je crois que
vous avez également pu vous entretenir
avant leur arrivée à la centrale vous
avez interviewé raphaël grossi donc le
directeur de l'aiea il vous a fait part
de sa détermination ne reculerons pas at
il dit
oui absolument raphaël grossi a été très
clair ils veulent aller au bout de cette
mission c'est ce qu'ils nous ont dit ce
matin et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui est
arrivé ils sont arrivés sur place mais
très clairement raphaël grossi a fait
état du fait qu'il avait été briefé par
les autorités militaires ukrainienne
qu'il était au courant de ce qui se
passait sur le plan militaire autour de
la centrale on a vu cette délégation de
l'eeie à se préparer ce matin enfilé les
gilets pare-balles vérifier les
véhicules on avait les chauffeurs qui
s'assuraient que tout tout irait bien
sûr ces quatre quatre blindés un long
convoi de quatre 4 blindés et qui est
parti en direction de cette centrale de
zappos ridja le directeur général aussi
qui hier soir faisait état du fait que
selon lui eh bien il avait rassemblé une
équipe d'ingénieurs suffisamment pointus
pour s'assurer et bien qu'il serait pas
possible de cacher quoi que ce soit à
cette délégation de l'aiea et puis
dernière chose que raphaël grossi a
précisé ce matin c'était
qu'effectivement il espère installer une
mission sur place une mission permanente
qui l'a décrite comme étant neutre
impartiale et objective pour s'assurer
et bien que la sécurité de cette
centrale soit effectivement monitorer de
manière internationale et qu'elle puisse
être garantie james profite de votre
présence puisque on a du mal à joindre
notre invité karine et review
est ce que vous en savez plus sur les
combats qui se poursuivent dans le sud
puisque depuis lundi les autorités
ukrainiennes ont lancé leur contre
offensive
c'est très très difficile de savoir
exactement ce qui se passe dans la
région de kherson effectivement ou une
contre offensive a été lancée il y a
deux ou trois jours maintenant
effectivement nous avons entendu des
informations émanant des autorités
ukrainiennes selon lesquelles il y avait
eu que les lignes russes avaient été
enfoncés à proximité de kherson il
précisait d'ailleurs que les combattants
avaient tout simplement déserté leurs
positions côté russe côté russe on
affirme linverse on affirme que cette
contre attaque n'a pas été un succès ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il ya des combats
qui font rage dans cette région à
l'heure où je vous parle en revanche on
ne peut pas y accéder pour l'instant à
la zone a été totalement fermée à la
presse et ce pour plusieurs jours jusqu
au 5 au 7 septembre donc il n'est pas
possible de se rapprocher des lieux des
combats ce qu'on sait en revanche c'est
qu'effectivement il y a notamment des
réfugiés et des personnes qui fuient la
zone en direction notamment de
mycologues pour échapper à ces combats
on sait également que dans les semaines
qui ont précédé et bien cette attaque a
été préparé par les ukrainiens et qui
ont notamment
bombardé tous les ponts qui reliait
carson à l'autre rive du nièvre où se
trouve le territoire occupé le reste du
territoire occupé par la russie et
notamment l'accès à la crimée ce qui
évidemment bloque l'arrivée de renforts
et de matériel depuis la russie vers
cette zone de combat désormais intense
où effectivement les ukrainiens avant ce
qu'ils sont en train de conquérir
village après village merci beaucoup
pour ce point complet james